I wanted to discuss about the different
research specialization tracks that you
can work on in the research fellowship
program so there are several tracks that
you can work on one of them is oncology
oncology research focuses on cancer
related studies and therapies then you
have Precision medicine that emphasizes
personalized Health Care based on
individual genetics and characteristics
then you have infectious diseases that
explode diseases caused by pathogens
such as bacteria viruses and fungi then
are metabolic disorders that Encompass
research on conditions like diabetes and
obesity then you have neuros signs that
investigates the brain and the nervous
system to understand the cognition and
disorders and then there are Fields like
system biology agriculture space omics
and chem informatics system biology
studies complex biological systems and
their interactions agriculture research
centers on improving crop yield and
sustainability and space omix examines
omix data in space environments for
space exploration a very interesting
field that's coming up and then you have
chem informatics that focuses on
computational methods for chemical
research we have met a lot of research
vs and some of them come with an idea
what they want to work on a topic or a
field that they want to work on with and
different types of data that they want
to explore but we also meet a lot of
newbies who are not sure are not clear
which specific path do they want to
select that's why we wanted to discuss
about the different tracks that you can
pick your research question from and get
started so we have these research
questions that we are already working on
and also we have uh the
pre-analysis of the of these different
components already done and you would be
responsible to carry out a literature
review and work on the analysis and
interpretation a customized analysis
that will tell you that you have to work
on so you get the halfway done and half
work done and then you have to work on
the analysis and the interpretation now
I'll tell you about some of the
predefined research questions that we
are proposing today for different
research specialization tracks
you can pick any one of these predefined
research questions if you're interested
to get a taste of the different research
tracks or different types of omx
analysis for your um experience or
Project work the first one is oncology
it is one of the exciting areas of
research to understand how the specific
genetic mutations can lead to resistance
to cancer drugs and here we are looking
for ways to develop a targeted therapy
to overcome the resistance another focus
is to identify the unique molecular
signatures and the biomarkers that are
associated with the progression of
breast cancer which can lead to more
personalized treatment approaches for
patients now these are the two topics
for oncology I have just specified two
such questions for each of the tracks
but if you wish to work on a different
uh specific track we can have a call and
we can let you know about the other
topics that we are working on as well
the next is a Precision medicine so
Precision medicine is all about
tailoring treatments to individual
patients and we are researching how to
identify the genetic and the molecular
markers that can predict how a person
would respond to specific medication and
this can lead to highly personalized
treatment plans additionally we are
investigating the genetic factors that
affect drug metabolism helping us
optimize the drug
prescriptions next is infectious
diseases so here we are exploring the
genetic diversity and the evolution of
the influenza virus in different regions
and this knowledge can help us design uh
either better vaccines or antiviral
drugs a better therapeutic approach in
short and we would also like to study
the transmission dynamics of diseases
like uh malaria aiming to reduce their
spread in endemic
regions so that was about these three
different tracks and what topics are we
focusing on the next one is neuroscience
so in Neuroscience we are focused on
understanding the underlying molecular
and cellular mechanisms of neurod
degenerative diseases like Alzheimer's
or Parkinson's and our goal is to
develop Innovative therapies to slow or
Hall disease progressions and we are
also exploring how genetics and
epigenetics influence brain development
and the risk of mental health disorders
like schizophrenia aiming to identify
early biomarkers for early
intervention another field is
agriculture where we want to look at
ways to optimize crop breeding using
genomic data and also we are studying
the the genetic factors and metabolic
pathways that make a plant resistant to
pests or diseases and diseases with the
aim of promoting sustainable and
eco-friendly farming
practices next is metabolic re uh
disorders metabolic disorders research
centers on understanding the molecular
factors that contributes to condition
like insulin resistance in type two
diabetes so we are working on targeted
therapies to improve insulin sensitivity
and additionally we also want to
investigate the metabolic underpinnings
of obesity and its related Health
complications such as fatty liver
disease and our goal is to develop
personalized interventions for weight
management last but not the least is
space
omx why space omix so in the fascinating
realm of space omx we are researching
how Extended space missions affect the
human microbiome and this knowledge can
help us develop strategies to mitigate
health risks associated with microbiome
changes during space travel we are also
exploring the genomic and the proteomic
changes in organisms export to extreme
conditions in space and this information
can um this specific information would
inform the development of biot
technological solutions for space
exploration as well as
colonization these were some thingss
that I wanted to discuss some topics
that we are working on and have plans to
work on and also uh there are other
fields that uh I have not discussed in
Greater detail but if you're interested
let us know you can email us we can uh
have an exploratory call with you and
discuss and those FS would be around
Ching formatics that we can uh discuss
specifically around Kim informatics